one you're looking at the future of
space travel
built by a private company spacex
starship is designed to transport people
deeper into space than ever before
and possibly take 100 people at a time
to mars
the first high altitude test flight of
the starship prototype was carried out
in december
stunning onlookers with a landing flip
maneuver that until that point
had never been done the reusable
spacecraft stabilizes itself in a
controlled fall before landing
which didn't go so well the first time
test vehicles are built to fail so that
later versions don't
data from test flights are used to make
improvements to the production line in
texas
along the u.s mexican border the
company's founder elon musk says they'll
go through around 20 prototypes before
it's operational
starship will eventually tower 120
meters in the sky atop what's called
a super heavy rocket more powerful than
the saturn v
used for the apollo missions to the moon
and it'll launch from the sea
spacex recently purchased two
decommissioned oil rigs for three and a
half million dollars each
and is converting them into floating
spaceports
musk says 1 000 starships will be needed
to build a city on mars
and he's committing billions from his
personal wealth to finance it
do you want the future where we become a
space spring civilization
and are in many worlds and out there
among the stars or one where we are
forever confined to earth and i say it
is the first
and and i hope you agree with me
fully reusable transportation systems
have significantly reduced costs for
each launch
for humans and cargo multiple ships then
start building out the city
then making the city bigger even bigger
even after defying expectations
musk's critics doubt his billions will
be enough to finance his dreams
a vision that will likely cost trillions
of dollars to realize
and will depend on future technology not
yet invented
but for now the next starship is fully
assembled and nearly ready for launch
andrew chappelle al jazeera